from an ai perspective do you think ai
systems convention design games that are
optimally compelling to humans
well that's an interesting question you
know sometimes i get asked about uh ai
and creativity and and this and the way
i answered that is relevant to that
question which is that i think they're
different levels of creativity one could
say so i think um if we define
creativity as coming up with something
original right that's that's useful for
a purpose then you know i think the kind
of lowest level of creativity is like an
interpolation so an averaging of all the
examples you see so maybe a very basic
ai system could say you could have that
so you show it millions of pictures of
cats and then you say give me an average
looking cat right generate me an average
looking cat i would call that
interpolation then there's extrapolation
which something like alphago showed so
alphago played you know millions of
games of go against itself um and then
it came up with brilliant new ideas like
move 37 and game two brilliant motif
strategies and go that that no humans
had ever thought of even though we've
played it for thousands of years and
professionally for hundreds of years so
that that i call that extrapolation but
then that's still there's still a level
above that which is you know you could
call out the box thinking or true
innovation which is could you invent go
right could you invent chess and not
just come up with a brilliant chess move
or brilliant go move but can you can you
actually invent chess or something as
good as chess or go
and i think one day
ai could but what's missing is how would
you even specify that task to a a
program right now and the way i would do
it if i was best telling a human to do
it or a games designer a human games
designer to do it is i would say
something like go i would say um
come up with a game that only takes five
minutes to learn which go does because
it's got simple rules but many lifetimes
to master right or impossible to master
in one lifetime because so deep and so
complex um and then it's aesthetically
beautiful uh and also uh it can be
completed in three or four hours of
gameplay time which is you know useful
for our us you know in in a human day
and so um you might specify this side of
high level concepts like that and then
you know with that and maybe a few other
things uh one could imagine that go
satisfies uh those those constraints um
but the problem is is that we we're not
able to specify abstract notions like
that high-level abstract notions like
that yet to our ai systems um and i
think there's still something missing
there in terms of
high-level concepts or abstractions that
they truly understand and they're you
know combinable and compositional um so
for the moment
i think ai is capable of doing
interpolation extrapolation but not true
invention so coming up with rule sets
uh and optimizing
with complicated objectives around those
rule sets we can't currently do but you
could take a specific rule set
and then run a kind of self-play
experiment to see how long
just observe how an ai system from
scratch learns how long is that journey
of learning and maybe if it satisfies
some of those other things you mentioned
in terms of quickness to learn and so on
and you could see a long journey to
master for even an ai system then you
could say that this is a promising game
but it would be nice to do almost like
alpha codes or programming rules so
generating rules that kind of
uh
that automate even that part of the
generation of rules so i have thought
about systems actually um that i think
would be amazing in in for a games
designer if you could have a system that
um takes your game plays it tens of
millions of times maybe overnight and
then self balances the rules better so
it tweaks the the rules and the maybe
the equations and the and the and the
parameters so that the game uh is more
balanced the units in the game or uh
some of the rules could be tweaked so
it's a bit of like a giving a base set
and then allowing uh monte carlo tree
search or something like that to sort of
explore it right and i think that would
be super super a powerful tool actually
for for balancing auto balancing a game
which usually takes
thousands of hours from hundreds of
games human games testers normally to to
balance someone you know game like
starcraft uh which is you know blizzard
are amazing at balancing their games but
it takes them years and years and years
so one could imagine at some point when
this uh this stuff becomes uh efficient
enough to you know you might better do
that like overnight do you think a game
that is optimal designed by nai system
would look very much like uh planet
earth
maybe maybe certainly the sort of game i
would love to make is is and i've tried
you know my in my game's career the
game's design career you know my first
big game was designing a theme park an
amusement park then uh with games like
republic i tried to you know have games
where we designed whole cities and and
allowed you to play in so and of course
people like will wright have written
games like sim earth uh trying to
simulate the whole of earth pretty
tricky but um i see earth i haven't
actually played that one so what is it
does it it's incorporative evolution
yeah it has evolution and it's sort of
um it tries to it sort of treats it as
an entire biosphere but from quite a
high level um so
nice to be able to sort of zoom in zoom
out zoom in exactly so obviously it
couldn't do that was in the night i
think he wrote that in the 90s so it
couldn't you know it wasn't he wasn't
able to do that but that that would be
uh obviously the ultimate sandbox game
of course
you